[Music]
we empty out all the money in the cash
register
[Music]
and right now reg brown taking the stage
guaranteed at least second placement uh
but he's going to need to pull out all
the stops to take out reigning champion
quarterback that flex my friend that
move actually is called the spirit of
detroit look at those muscles you know
what interesting that you say that it
sort of reminds me of the the the
monument when you come into detroit
reggie brown just that giant black fist
yes yes indeed welcome to the welcome to
the midwest the paris of the midwest
look at this he really has impressed me
today oh but i tell you what now the
four-time reigning champion quarter
black yard look at him coming out with
the grace of a swan of course his
signature uh ranger panties available at
crowder shop which is what this is all
about but the way that he moves in them
is that of a dancer i tell you what god
ran out of charm when he put his mold in
the
oven he did he used all of it from what
i understand too quarter black was
eating a sundae before hold on one
moment
here comes the oh there it is the double
glute flex well that is going to be hard
to beat i'm gonna change these pants
he's a champion but he is coming in
tonight like a contender look at this
going to flex that thigh dude just did
an awful job of applying that tanning
lotion and oh the judges have to say yes
it is well quarter black garrett no
surprise here that will be his fifth mr
crowder shop title reg brown being a
good sport but you can just see on his
face that he has no clue as to how this
happened and i think that uh folks out
there of course can get their own
answers at crowdershop.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
um
well all right then
wow
that's the sound of uh well i guess
that's the sound of monday because
you've gone you've gone a few a few days
without hearing that by the way someone
just asked me this week and they said
wait a second wait a second is that
brian stelter in your intro i said it's
like you don't know me at all
of course it is seen the program because
he
is my sunshine
and there ain't going to be any stealth
when he's gone
please cnn
keep him
forever forever
uh we have a lot to get to here today
look russia ukraine is going on but of
course the big story coming out of there
is this uh you know this bombing
happening near the border of poland so
people are freaking out about it i'm not
uh but the story that is more important
is hey i don't know if you know this
russia reaching out to china who could
have possibly predicted that one
i am shocked when everyone was praising
the sanctions and everyone was saying
this is great we need to be tough on
russia and put in sanctions that punish
the people and not the oligarchs
themselves we said you might be driving
them into the arms of china and here we
are we'll talk about that but more
importantly than
more important than that i want to talk
about pedophiles targeting your children
this is something that i know you've
probably all seen the peat butt king's
husband having the kids pledge
allegiance to the gay flag
which is weird but there are also uh
sexy time summer camps directly
targeting children and this is one of
those things remember people used to say
oh hold on a second well now you're
making the argument whatever whatever it
was could be gay marriage could be trans
could be puberty blockers you're making
the argument that it's going to
normalize pedophilia look behind you
there's a slippery slope it's all the
way back next to a nuclear reactor just
like the beijing olympics so
[Laughter]
here we are the most innocent among us
another thing i won't be here thursday
dave will be phil in hosting because we
have a big change my mind coming up next
week yes so i'll be out filming this uh
but
aside from that if we don't let you know
and there is a show thursday at state
but if we don't let you know that
there's no show
what that means is we are still
streaming live rumble you can go there
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
or of course we do a full other hour of
uh of programming at mug club live
earthquaker.com every day that's the
best place to watch it yeah
all right
gerald a how are you he's here with me i
am well how are you sir i didn't i
didn't know i was so tired yesterday i
had no idea that the clocks got changed
over i i would vote for biden if he
ended daylight savings time i'm a
one-issue voter yeah just i'm done one
issue voter i guarantee you he doesn't
know that the clocks are changed over
see this is why they probably didn't
tell him so they could get some work
done without him just mr president sign
here what day like time and savings and
stuff that's good to save
what are we doing saving
what take it back take a penny leave a
penny huh
and uh dave is out sick today mr landau
but uh in his place is uh pop's crowder
dave calls him crawdaddy i don't call
him crawdaddy how are you sir b team
yeah you know nobody rants more about
daylight savings time than one tim the
tool man taylor ah furious tim the
toolman hates it hate it why
it's stupid it's because it messes your
whole system up like i'll feel this for
like two weeks that could you've told
yourself i don't think it's so much that
so much as the uh the nitrous the
poppers that well wow and if you know
this immediate brain damage so uh and my
question of the day before we move on
here is is is anyone actually buying are
any of you buying the whole putin is the
reason for economic woes schtick
that we're hearing from kamala harris
and joe biden i mean they're mad about
it they want you to know that the reason
you're paying 409 at the pump is uh is
because of putin because also the reason
you're paying 409 for 409
that'd be a deal
or fantastic whichever cleaner you
prefer pine saw einsall hand smell
but before we uh move on to that i just
uh just spoiled it i'm not buying it um
ron desantis i don't know if you know
this governor of florida
he's now triggered a whole new slew
of uh leftist
hysteric hystericists is that a word i'm
going to make it a word
with the parental rights and education
bill and so now if you go on tick tock
you go on instagram you know if you go
into the belly of the beast if you go
into the nothing you will see
all of these um
i can't use that word
you'll see all of these all right people
say it with me gay
come on you can do better than that when
i say gay you say gay
gay gay
[Music]
hey i don't know if y'all knew this but
gay hip hip okay stay gay every day
okay
yeah nothing uh nothing to win people to
your cause like being obnoxiously
unfunny and gay and andy with the polls
not knowing how to end it yeah not
knowing there's no end to the sketch no
i mean sketch i use that term loosely i
was with him for a bit there's uh okay
we got it and ended went on for another
four minutes yeah went out for another
four minutes and uh just you just this
gay person i don't know if a guy i don't
i have no idea but anything uh i wanted
you to hear him hit the high note right
that's that's the thing with a lot of
gay guys you're like look i can do the
mariah carey look mariah carey can't do
the mariah carey only celine dion can do
the mariah carey
you ever heard her live sets
that's awesome i know why the mariah
carey thing is a thing but
this is predicated on the idea that
don't say gay right it's not in the bill
it's not the bill so you i mean you're
tilting at windmills man you have no id
no like i'm gonna say gay but what are
you protesting you're not they didn't
say you can't say gay no they said
basically we don't want to talk about
sex to four to eight year olds and why
would you not want to do that well we'll
get to sexy summer camp in a bit yeah
why would you want a sexual how is that
not pedophilia by the way promoting sex
education to four and five and six years
it's not because because they're not
acting on it it's just pedophilia
yearning
it's it's pseudo pedophilia
it's pedophilia so yeah
thank you okay okay okay
all right nothing like perpetuating the
original stereotype if i did that you'd
be like that's homophobic not all gay
people are like that i'm not saying all
gay people are like that i'm saying
you're like that and it's disgusting no
his little ethel merman line didn't do
it yes exactly
gay gay gay went the trolley
it's a bit of an audition really oh gosh
there's there's a share wall on that
man's household somewhere
okay
with yarn just tied all over yes yes
exactly
there's a barbra streisand hair puppet
so nancy pelosi talking about this she
uh she wants you to know something
because she doesn't know anything so she
wants you to know something and she was
given these talking points and this is
one of the again if you get nothing else
from this program it's it's learning how
to think
learning how to sort of uh i guess uh
administer a sniff test i've always said
this for example if you look at sports
uh someone can maybe look like they're
not on steroids and be on steroids but
if someone looks like they're on
steroids they're probably on steroids
yeah right so that's the eyeball test
chael son and a friend of mine talks
about that it's very rare that you think
someone is on steroids and they're not
it's very rare if someone says something
that appears to be nonsensical
and it actually makes sense
because she wants you to believe that
the government's government's record
spending the government's record
printing right
which historically has had
a direct effect on inflation always uh
she wants you
to believe that government spending will
not increase
the debt
uh and is actually helping the economy
and also the economy is bad because of
course putin so when we're having this
discussion it's important to dispel some
of those who say well is the government
spending no it isn't
but everyone's going to use doing the
exact reverse reducing the national debt
is not inflationary
b
we don't want to reduce the um
increase in jobs and we're very proud of
this president breaking records
historic numbers of jobs
we're paying very close attention to it
but this
starts
with boom
because of the global inflation for
reasons beyond gas
gas price global inflation is something
that we have to deal with
globally
it just makes common sense first off i i
wish again rules for thee but not for me
you imagine dealing with your credit
card company that way right yeah we're
calling from diners club you're uh
you've overspent you're above your limit
i thought i thought that if i spent more
the debt uh i was under the impression
that it went away
and really that sounds like a global
problem that you need to deal with is
that why you bought a thousand dollar
hyundai well they're all ninety thousand
dollars now because the economy's rip
roaring
steny hoyer looked very confused yes
very cute you stand back here uh look
her hand signals she's all over the
place with this we don't wanna
you can't mock the parkinson's that's a
parkinson's shake
don't take a soda from her she italian
so um
let me just fact check that really
quickly no new jobs have been added
since the peak of 2019. none not one i
know you're thinking maybe some no now
uh before putin invaded ukraine
inflation hit a 40-year high of 7.5 and
that's not including the housing cost
increase which we know would put it
above 11 percent uh
gas prices went up 57 in 2021 just over
there so
is that all yeah
so that's all pre-putin no
and this is the issue when people say
hey why are these why are these people
supporting putin no no what happens is
when you try and make one person the
scapegoat for everything right someone
coming in saying no no putin is not the
reason for the high gas prices they say
why are you a putin apologist i'm not
i'm a you're lying apologist the gas
prices were already on their way up and
i think it's cpi that you're referring
to if you throw in the housing stuff
it'll be over 11 right right it'll be
over 11. yeah yeah exactly but it's
wonderful they can just change the way
that they measure inflation yeah yeah
they just go wow don't don't include it
yeah don't include it but isn't that
what do we use historically to do we
usually include it we often do yes are
you including it now we thought that it
would be better not to hey if i put my
income on my tax return it means that i
have to pay more money so just don't
include it okay good good advice yeah
well also by the way if you uh deduction
if you pay more in taxes
the debt gets wiped away does it really
i have no idea how so i don't know how
economies work we can spend trillions
more dollars
the debt goes down
yeah yeah
what do you think happened
you know i really i guess i didn't know
i didn't understand it either yeah i'm
just gonna be honest but i'm thankful
for nancy pelosi and paul krugman to
have broken it down for me yeah yeah
spend more to have less debt
how do you spend more do you print more
wait
yeah then why tax more at all i never
understand that there's something like
all right we need to increase your tax
rate
what are you doing over there i just you
don't even know how much more taxes
you just printed another billion dollars
no no no we need to make sure that we uh
get it from your what's going to go into
your 401k
that's another two billion dollars where
you just gotta increase your marginal
tax rate
you're an [ __ ] pay your fair share
yeah printing money now sounds like the
counting money at the bank
it really is now that's how i assume it
works different
i don't know leonardo dicaprio in france
crying out loud
what do you think is going to happen you
spend more you think you decrease that
this is the issue with the left they
actually no i don't know if they believe
it i really don't know if nancy pelosi
believes this or if she just wants you
to believe it but anyone who believes
that spending more decreases the debt
doesn't really understand uh what
spending actually is anyone who thinks
that printing more money therefore
making money less valuable understanding
the general concept of scarcity
understands very simply that of course
that'll make inflation worse and you can
see that you can see that with almost
any time that we've printed more money
you can see that with uh federal reserve
policies it's it's not that hard to
track and it's not even something that
leftist economists really argue they
argue that overall it's better in the
long term right that's what they used to
argue well in the long term it'll help
us get the deficit down even though we
have to deal with inflation now and
printing now they just go no no no
spending more gets rid of the debt and
printing money actually makes money
worth more so it's good
and brondo does your body good yes it
does because it's got what plants need
it's got electrolytes i think this is
going to work for them though they're
going to blame every single thing on
russia that they can and distract the
american people for midterms that's all
it is that's the only play that they
have right now does anyone remember
kovid no no what was that remember that
was a thing
i don't know if you i don't know if any
of you guys are history buffs here but
[Laughter]
the last two years
were hell on earth because of this thing
called uh kovid19 yeah the tsar's
coronavirus ii
it was a sequel that was better than the
original um
barely now it's gone
so you know you got that going for you
which is good all i took was russia
invading ukraine yeah and i think even
people on the left are starting to
realize this so you this is almost where
the marching orders aren't going uh
they're not going down the ranks like
they used to and i will say this bill
maher you know full disclosure i've
spoken with the people who work at that
show before where they had reached out
to me so i do have a hunch
we talked about some of the jokes word
for word that had taken place on his
show regarding the beijing olympics and
uh the aids uh pandemic you know
according to fauci
but he's run into the same kind of
content again i think the person i spoke
with might be watching this show here so
let me just kind of give this to you mar
uh now uh discussing um putin's long
tables every time i see a picture of
vladimir putin he's sitting by himself
at the end of a ridiculously long table
all by himself he's like a cross between
ivan the terrible and howie mandel
laugh track
well no it's a laugh sign well yeah left
side yeah with guns pointed out when he
does this
right folks
it's a cross between mandel and putin
okay
not right folks
no no it's not but by the way i don't
know if you know this was us uh
discussing that uh then
well technically it's true we are the
largest producer but there's a let's
talk about look at that
was that donald trump there no no i
couldn't see who was at the end of the
table
is that no we built the tables then we
built the room around it yes it was like
come on guys
hey president trump [ __ ] you guys
send it down to him come over here and
say to my face i don't have the time
table is uh filled with wheat it's quite
so big yes it's also act as a great
insulator yes it's a vacuum sealed with
wheat yeah exactly what a stupid table
well that's how they measure dicks in
russia is these giant stupid and how far
you can put people you need to be able
to pass papers between down the table he
just walks over to he's just walking
over to the white house he's like
okay and you guys can comment below
that's the best thing uh that you can do
for the algorithms who wore it better
and by ward i mean wrote it produced it
and performed it
i want more of trump and putin at the
long table yeah
actually that was spontaneous with you
guys his was written but yeah yeah
that's true yeah that is that is true
wait you so they pre-planned that and
that's that's what we got well this
brings us to another thing though
because bill maher was even saying hey
why didn't putin attack the united
states uh when donald trump was
president yeah and i've always said
that's because he's just crazy enough
that you think he might do it
right crazy beats big every time
and uh now we're hearing that exact same
sentiment echoed from people who would
have never dared to say this before so
this brings us to you know trevor noah
this week is he
if we want to hear from is he secretly
based
[Music]
it's the first time i saw that stupid
stinger
really
i think we know it's pretty good barack
obama's watching this show
of course i don't want to watch the show
i'll i'll get all wee-weed up shut up he
waits for your impressions he stopped
making things up he's doing me look
making up terms no that's how we uh
that's how we said it and uh when i was
raised in chicago kenya indonesia uh
shut up hawaii hawaii
right next to the rock who did that uh
hobbs and shaw film that uh you know uh
where he uh he can't speak a word of
simone but wants to tell you that it's
his roots
[Laughter]
that man has never never been this he
has an upper chest tattoo he's also he's
yeah
and his forehead keeps growing to the
size of a driving movie screaming oh
that's what steroids do
[Laughter]
you gotta play it all the way to the end
if you're gonna do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i was gonna dick sports recently and i'm
the jumbotron on the jumbotron they
showed the rock doing curls with the 30s
really yeah
that surprises me wow well you know what
there's no he's a strong guy he's a big
strong guy but uh he hasn't you know
never touched us it's all natural
so trevor noah uh implied that not only
again did
donald trump keep people like putin in
line but
it almost comes into the subtext here
that he may miss him
he may be longing for him
watch
there is no denying that saudi arabia
isn't playing ball with joe biden
and you know what you can say what you
want but this
would have never happened to donald
trump
never
no one was ever ignoring donald trump's
calls
yeah because if you ignored donald
trump's calls you didn't know how he
would respond
maybe he'd send an angry tweet
or maybe he just like banned your
country from everything you don't know
that's why i bet in these situations
biden actually wishes that he could hire
trump to step in as president wild card
you know just keep everyone on their
toes
because if trump was calling you best
believe the uae they'll be racing to
pick up the phone oh mr trump mr trump
we're here we're here hello too late
ahmed you made me way two rings we're
bombing the uae and the ufc just in case
i mean it's literally the words that we
use was he kept them on their toes
so you ca you know what comment comment
you think trevor noah is secretly based
or do you think that maybe now here's
what i think is happening
they always wanted to make it seem as
though they were rebelling against the
man right and it's pretty tough to do
that when you run hollywood when you run
media when you run most of washington dc
including a lot of the republicans right
when you run education
all of these institutions and you just
you have one scapegoat with donald trump
but you can still claim like yeah yeah
we're sticking it to the man because
donald trump is the authority figure and
now at this point they control
everything and i think they realize that
it's maybe not
conducive toward reaching a young
audience to do the bidding of a 94 year
old geriatric incontinent president so i
think
[Laughter]
i think at this point they're just
saying well we okay we have to do a
little bit of a give and take i don't
think he's secretly based i think what
he just said is true it echoes what
we've been saying for years uh but i
think right now they're probably getting
some some focused studies from frank
luntz and his awful sneakers in toupee
saying people don't like it when you
just go out and do the bidding for the
white house right well the truth is too
obvious now right you know that that is
absolutely what he said is absolutely
true the uae would pick up the phone if
donald trump called period done that
would happen russia did not invade
ukraine under donald trump period this
is the truth he's just saying what we
already know today if they were on the
if they were on the phone with former
vice president joe biden today and they
had call waiting from donald trump like
uh hello hello hello former vice
president i have to call you back and
then we go straight yeah to donald trump
i think even the emasculated men on the
left
appreciate a firm hand in the tiller of
the ship i i think they oh yeah they
feel safer
even if they don't admit it yeah well i
also think trevor noah should steer
clear of you know doing impressions
why don't they help the guy out give him
some cutaways some something to you know
give him some quality they did darren
that's the a-game yeah
they put a flag up over his head while
he did something like i said that's as
good as it gets wow yeah for 20 mil
that's all he gets yeah yeah i know
that's it i'm not better about it no
hey speaking of which by the way lot of
crowder.com dave's not here but dave and
i are on tour you can go and check them
out they're uh i don't know if there are
tickets to tulsa they might so we still
have some tulsa tickets left so you can
go on the website for that but really
promoting the second show uh june 18th
colorado springs colorado that's right
there's a second show that should be
live because many of you were
complaining the show sold out too
quickly so june 18th colorado springs
we've added a second show we will see
you there livestream.com tour okay
here's something with kamala harris i
wanted to talk about because i didn't
know that this was possible you know
what i'm about to talk about uh there
pops crowder it was surprising
really surprising dave just called him
this morning he was half asleep he's
like what huh i got to be in third chair
i will you'll understand why i was so
surprised because i didn't i
i'm jealous and you'll understand why so
over the weekend she was asked
a question about inflation and just gave
this absolutely bizarre nonsensical
answer that had nothing to do with it
not to be fair i'll go in to where she
kind of addressed it later on but this
is the unedited sequence of events with
the question and her answer
uh
this is why people are calling her visit
an embarrassment watch president biden
has said that americans will feel some
pain for the sake of defending freedom
and liberty
but there does seem to be no end game in
sight
how long should americans expect how
long should we be bracing for
this really sort of
historic inflation and some
unprecedented gas prices
[Laughter]
help
in terms of uh the discussions that the
president
johannes and i had they ranged in
subject including the issue of the black
sea and i'll let him
explain in more detail as he would like
but
we are again
fully aware and apprised because we are
in constant communication
with the president with his
administration here
about the concerns that they have about
the entire region and frankly the
vulnerability
all you have to do is look at the map
and and see that that where romania
exists geographically
and as
is the case for our allies on the
eastern flank
that there are potential vulnerabilities
which is why we say very clearly we will
dedicate and have been especially
enhancing over the last
few weeks
our support based on their current needs
you can do that
you can
wait some what can i can you do that in
marriage no where were you yeah i
actually think that the chicken piccata
you made last night was pretty good
little salty but uh i do appreciate that
you made it and uh i'm uh going to bed
no no where were you yeah no you know i
do you know typically i prefer veal
piccata but uh you know what the way you
dressed it up was pretty good so uh i'm
going to bed love you i didn't know you
could just not answer the question i
just i didn't just move on to something
else and also answer that would-be
question
poorly yeah well if you look at the map
you'll see that the proximity to hell
means you know that might be hot yeah
exactly like what when she feels the
fires of hell at her soul on a daily
basis
she's very familiar with it now here's
the thing is is there was a question
that was asked of her right first and
before that there was a question asked
of the romanian president yeah and she
instead decided i want to answer the
romanian president's question
even though i don't know what i'm
talking about
but to be fair
she got to it a little bit through it a
little later on on the inflation it's
not much better and this is
backstage unfortunate experience all of
us right now who are not in ukraine
of witnessing
horror like a wind-up robot so we are
committed in everything we are doing
and yes then the president did say in
the state of the union yes
there is a price to pay for democracy
you've got to stand with your friends
and as everybody knows even in your
personal life
that's it that's the answer to those
friendships based on
common principles and values
sometimes it's difficult
often it ain't easy
so that's what we're doing it ain't it
ain't easy she went back to her days of
uh you know having her city board at uh
with willie brown horror name easy mama
oh remain easy i didn't like that girl
in high school much less as vice
president like
sometimes it ain't easy it ain't easy
baby
like why you do this in romania
you do not like this what is she doing
by the way are you indian or are you
black i don't understand i thought you
were singing would be i i
i don't know what you are oh thank god
she knows romania close to russia
starting point by the way i can make you
president if you sleep with me in
trailer so
what is that plaintiff whale in her
voice that she right on the cusp of
tears that she's hoping will join her in
her emotion yeah does it all the time
which is very difficult when you're a
sociopath and you don't have the emotion
she's going through her
she's going through her mental rolodex
kind of like in terminator 2 where he
said give me your clothes your bike and
your boots she's going oh okay how do
human beings respond
whale it ain't easy
the least popular candidate in the
history well
certainly in all of the primaries i'd
like to say in the history of primaries
but i don't really know that could be
john kasich for republicans i mean no
one likes you kasich but she is worse
than kasich for the democrats and she
was made vice president and sent over
there yeah do that and they drummed
chelsea gabbard out of the core you know
well yeah of course yeah anybody else's
primaries but i get it it's the price we
pay for democracy i see that's that's uh
how else would we have the safest uh
uh election in the history of uh
electioning
safe and secure democracy right yeah
because uh ukraine is a is a bastion of
democracy in freedom it's not like there
was a government that was effectively
installed that people also wanted uh
here in the west it's not like uh here
in the united states you forced people
to wear masks and you tried to enforce
vaccine mandates and you tried to
enforce vaccine passports and you locked
down businesses uh indefinitely so no
yeah democracy this is what they always
say they always say democracy they don't
really care about freedom no and we're
not a we are not a democracy
you can't be free in a true democracy a
true democracy is mob rule that's why we
are a constitutional republic a
democratic republic you can't just have
democracy where you vote on everything
because guess what that makes it too
easy to pander and give people free
stuff you know like you're doing your
entire platform yeah that's the entire
platform
which also brings us to really we're
talking about freedom right democracy
sorry i see i'm still thinking about
freedom
the real thing yeah the real thing
freedom is what matters anyone who uses
the term equity instead of equality
discount what they say bye
that's it it's a silly thing you can
either have equality or you can have
equity equity has to be enforced at the
expense of equality
just to be clear and it's the same thing
when these people say democracy
democracy democracy they use democracy
at the cost of freedom they say well
most people want
you to be taxed and pay for socialized
health care well hold on that's not
a constitutional right well most people
don't believe that you should be able to
have a semi-automatic rifle i don't care
what most people say because freedom
they want democracy in their graven
image at the cost of freedom notice the
language they say equity they don't say
equality they focus on democracy because
freedom is like garlic to a vampire just
be just just
sniff test right i want you to think
about looking at these things looking at
these issues critically when they're
saying
oh saying when they're when they're
spouting when they're regurgitating the
talking points be aware of the language
that they use and why they use it
there's a specific reason they discuss
democracy usually sometimes you'll hear
them pepper freedom in there before they
go right back to democracy but they want
democracy and they want to be hey where
are the people this is one thing i don't
understand where are all the people who
bitched about the united states being
the world police hmm
they're busy
coveted yeah
something trump there we go where are
they right no new wars under donald
trump and right now we're talking about
disastrous foreign policy with
afghanistan we're talking about
disastrous foreign policy right now with
russia and people are saying yeah i
stand with i stand with ukraine well
hold on a second
we're all the people we shouldn't be the
police of the world when we're going
into afghanistan hunting the taliban
you can agree or disagree with that if
you want to be a consistent sort of
non-interventionist but when you say
that's wrong and no war for oil and now
we're going we'd have to stand with
ukraine why
why it's a simple question you guys can
comment below i under i understand there
are reasonable people on both sides of
the ukraine issue however i don't think
it's possible
to hold an anti-war position or say that
the united states should not be the
police of the world
while saying we need to stand with
ukraine and supporting us going into
another potentially endless war i'm just
wondering where those folks have gone to
team america world police great film by
the way but it was a sentiment of a lot
of people why are we going into these
countries and interfering
now it seems like everyone's ready to do
it
because it's not your life just like
you're ready to spend someone else's
money you're ready to you know you're
ready to
expend someone else's life it's a
convenient distraction imagine this
happening at the beginning of biden's
term
i think it would be very different yeah
right i think it would be decidedly
different if it's happening at the
beginning of his term because right now
like i said they have nothing to play on
for the midterms at all it is going to
be a shellacking they said yes i just
want to quote
chuck todd chuck todd with his penciled
on beer to try and make try and fool you
into thinking that he has a chin like we
don't know what you're up to
and so this is a convenient distraction
they're going to warmonger just enough
because they're not actually going to
want to go in i don't think the
democrats would support that i think
they're going to support sanctions as
much as possible they want to try and
paint anyone who doesn't exactly court
war as a putin puppet as a shill for
putin just like they tried to say that
putin hacked theology saki just said
that when she was talking with tick-tock
influencers the other days like of
course we know the 2016 election was
hacked by russia oh boy do you think she
believes that do you think she knows
better
this is the issue it really comes down
to at a certain point these are
verifiable
lies or verifiable inaccuracies so the
only question left is is it a lie or is
it ignorance
that's where we are that's the only
question left okay which brings us now
discussing this issue uh
with you it's this week's segment of
insane in uh the ukraine
[Music]
those are not functional shirts at all
no they're not
barely cover anything no it's really
more of a it's it's it's just it's a
it's dressing that's not very absorbent
yeah no they're not very absorbent and
believe me they will sweat
[Laughter]
it's like when you have those awful
table napkins you know i mean they're
like polyester for christmas and you
just end up smearing stuffing all over
your face yeah exactly
yeah glad we pulled out the good stuff
you just you look like you look like a
cannibal with cranberry sauce and blood
all over your mouth what happened what
what is this it's
why is there lacquer on this napkin
napkins shouldn't have lacquer
all right so you were telling me about
this too everyone was discussing elon
musk just kind of as a jumping off point
i love it what did he do so basically
elon musk he's he's not pulled any
punches lately on twitter he's almost
become like the donald trump of twitter
except without being you know quite mean
quite as mean as donald trump but he
basically said today i hereby challenge
vladimir putin to single combat and the
stakes are ukraine he would get his ass
kicked immediately he probably would but
i think it's hilarious that he said and
then he also do any research well i
think he did but somebody actually i
went through the timeline a little bit
and somebody said something to him like
are you serious bro i don't think you
could do that same thing you're saying
putin right right he's like i am 100
serious
does he mean unarmed i have no idea what
he means but i love it he wants to do it
with flamethrowers he's going to send
starlink in and uh you know that's and
then he all ends i think he's betting 20
years is is enough of a gap that he can
he could make up for any uh
expertise yeah i don't know i mean i
enjoy though that he's on there
i think it's fun yeah and he followed it
up by the way just because he wasn't
getting the kind of response that he
wanted look when you challenge somebody
to a fight and they ignore you you have
to take it one step further or you walk
away right he took one step further and
he actually tagged the official kremlin
account and said do you agree to this
battle
he's serious russia
what you got yeah and then they executed
julian assange
well that's not his they just made an
example of him uh putin's not impressed
with much he also said by the way elon
musk we can't do this without nuclear
energy when he was talking about this
transitioning to you know fossil fuel
free uh an energy economy that's fossil
fuel freezing europe without nuclear he
said yeah specifically he's like europe
right now should be building more
nuclear power plants if you don't want
to be dependent on russian gas and oil
or oil from the middle east because you
don't like the politics of some pla
build the plants now he's just a
mouthpiece for big oil that musk
[Laughter]
there's one thing i know about tesla
it's their mouthpiece for big oil i've
seen fern gully also tesla just
increased their prices and people are
bitching about it what do you think when
this administration told everybody to go
out and buy an electric vehicle that
they can't afford yeah and what about
supply chain stuff didn't you understand
the prices of everything have gone up by
the way can we just say i like teslas
too i'm just like you and this is not
this is not going to be flattering of
tesla but could it be like tesla powered
by coal that's the new yeah tagline no
it's not like they don't have a nickel
in them right nickel and all the other
rare earth minerals yeah cobalt
got any cobalt mines around i don't know
i don't know i don't even know how to
mine cobalt someone said you are locked
in this you are locked in this tower
until you learn how to mine cobalt and
they left like a cobalt mine near me
with all the tools that i need
yes it's a tower of wine it's a tower
with a trap door to a cobalt mine well
no in this situation it's a very
specific
tower architecture okay
i didn't i'm not the architect i'm not
the designer oh wow and they said you
will not get out here until you figure
out how to mine cobalt you would just
find a stephen crowder-shaped skeleton
80 years from be rapunzel yeah it'd be
rapunzel you would die and make sure you
left your hand with the middle finger up
just so that when they came in they'd be
a big fu yes
i had a cobalt uh ring at one point and
then i found out that because i i had a
tungsten ring and then i had a weird lip
and then i was like oh i'll get cobalt
and then i found out the tungsten they
crack but cobalt they can't crack but
it's too hard from the cut they're like
yeah by the way uh uh with cobalt they
can only get it off with diamond cutters
and then after the surgery when i
ballooned up and i couldn't get my ring
off i said that's it
that's it until i know that i'm one year
through this and rubberized fluid
retention the point is
it's stupid now
less than a month into uh the invasion
of ukraine uh russia is apparently
calling on
china for military and financial
assistance and this is coming from u.s
officials
uh that they've asked beijing and also
they were just talking about on cnn but
hold on oh hold on a second right now on
cnn they're saying pfizer fourth dose of
covet vaccine
is like hey hey
still hate about us
you know we measure this stuff quarter
to quarter yeah guys
i got a stock price to keep going i mean
they're they're still advertising on cnn
yeah they still joe lewis go back to
your bet here but that was my fault i
got a little animated did you get joe
lewis no that's me joe lewis
back to your bed joe lewis no no place
place all right
down
good boy because after all russia needs
more money and military power to beat up
on a defenseless neighbor well it is
embarrassing for them they're doing so
poorly how many more money
do you think putin lost he's like uh
ukraine uh who wants to take bets two
days three yeah two weeks later so the
guy who he's bet with they disappeared
it's a great way to get a scouting
report on the other team you get to see
how poorly they perform and
in game time yeah well the myth of the
russian military it's just a bunch of
drunken conscripts that's what people
don't understand it's not nearly people
think of this russian super soldier it's
not true often like the the idf people
will often say oh yeah i do krav maga
because i don't know if you notice he is
really defensive it's like yeah but they
all have to do it the reason that they
do some of the things they do for
example carrying israeli style is
because gal gadot is going to go in and
has no interest in learning firearm
safety so they have to reduce it to the
lowest common denominator people think
it's like everyone there is the most
effective fighting soldier no it's not
really true the russians they like to
get drunk and uh you know they can't
even beat ukraine well the idea soldiers
run out and pokey in the eye yeah
that works
you'll never see it coming that's true
look really yeah i don't know if this
will get us banned from youtube because
i'm revealing military secrets but
if this to ibf soldier
no can defend
so i far too dangerous to practice steve
yeah just don't do it even the national
security adviser uh jake sullivan
vowed swift retaliation if beijing were
to aid moscow right
would you sanction china if they did
help out russia
i'm not going to sit here publicly and
and brandish threats but what i will
tell you
is that we are communicating directly
privately to beijing
that there will absolutely be
consequences for
he looks like the pale guy in the
locations of asian efforts or support to
russia to backfill them we will not
allow that to go forward and allow there
to be
a lifeline to russia from these economic
sanctions from any country anywhere in
the world
but i thought he said he wasn't going to
sit there and brandish threats right we
will not allow this that's like a tuban
saying i'm not going to sit here and
show you my penis
or
sit here and brandish yes i'm not going
to sit here and brandish my wiener what
does he think that's doing then no no no
no they have to they have to sit under
the crippling economic sanctions that
have closed their stock market for weeks
that have made the ruble valueless
pretty much just to be thrown out into
the streets and have caused protests in
their country where they know they'll be
killed for protesting but if they so
much as ask somebody for help yeah that
is not a threat what did you think would
by the way they were totally fine with
sharing intelligence with china before
oh yeah the invasion we've talked about
that right i don't know if you remember
this but they shared intelligence with
china and now ah if you ask for china
for help and here's the thing who could
have predicted that this war might push
and specifically the sanctions
specifically the actions being taken
that were squeezing them who could have
predicted that this might push moscow
closer to beijing and thrust russia into
the arms of an unnatural ally china
you're going to have to learn how to
live differently
last week i think was it last week that
we reported uh visa mastercard visa
mastercard and a slew of other companies
but this one specifically on the
financial side they pulled out of russia
and basically what that did is that
pushed russia into the arms of china
again with union well how so oh union
pay the chinese yes exactly it's state
owned uh well yes chinese state owned
the payment system russia and china
should not be allies yeah they should
hate each other because russia now is
vehemently anti-communist at least
that's what putin says but we've seen
them now creating these alliances we've
talked about the wheat embargo yeah
that's a big deal of it there right
selling a ton of oil
well i'm surprised i pulled the clip
from march 9th we probably could have
pulled the one from like february 1st
[Laughter]
but that works too this was the
highlight of what we had said already
yeah that was a recap of what we've been
saying for months and here we are this
is this is the problem when you you
either are all in with war you've heard
me say this many times you either are
all in or you need to be all out you
can't just sort of you're basically
declaring war without declaring war
that's the problem with these economic
sanctions this is you end up creating
alliances and you talked about this i
mean back in february maybe yeah
certainly in february uh you know russia
and germany going into world war ii yeah
in world war one they were act i mean
bitter bitter enemies germany basically
defeated and crushed the russian
military in world war one and signed
signed off with them very early on
saying you know like this is this is
done right because we've just beaten the
crap out of you guys and so we had to
have the united states come in and so
you think what less than 20 years later
down the road you've got this same
situation developing and you would think
okay obviously it's basically the same
teams right
no they signed an armistice with them or
not an armistice sorry they signed a
non-aggression uh treaty with them and
that's the same kind of stuff where
you're looking at politics and you're
looking at kind of the economic
situation in the world and going we're
driving these people into unnatural
alliances that they will accept for a
time for for the record germany didn't
honor that i don't know well i i mean
i had mine fingers crossed well and they
went through ukraine not to honor it so
that seems to be the pathway
i'm not sure what's gonna happen the
ukraine as we call it zipat as we call
it the route to dominating russia
well and you made a really good point
about economic sanctions being war do
you remember when japan bombed pearl
harbor obviously well i wasn't there but
i believe it happened we talked about
one of the reasons for that is that 80
of japanese oil was coming from the
united states and then we started to
move on the place they were getting the
rest of their oil from or at least a
large portion of it
i'm not saying that they were justified
in attacking us but when you back
somebody into a corner you typically
leave them no other option than to go to
war with you right and economic
sanctions will do that especially if
they can align with somebody like china
and china and the truth is what should
have happened is if we look at world war
ii
is the united states if they were going
to stop supplying oil should have
immediately struck japan should have
immediately engaged in other words they
were half and they were half out and
when we ended up with pearl harbor where
the war came to our shores because a lot
of people don't realize we were taking
actions economically there were
sanctions but the war came to our
doorstep that's ultimately what happens
you push them into a corner and then
they feel like they've got to strike
first as far as violence otherwise they
have no other options
so if you're going to do that for
example japan it would have been a good
example you say all right that's it we
can't support these guys anymore and you
go to war you don't halfway do it it's
not a measure that works it's not an
approach that works and i'm just
wondering where all the anti-war people
have gone
they're busy yeah they're busy
uh and uh on sunday to um russian what
was it we were talking russian missiles
hit uh a base in western ukraine you
probably know about this but i want to
talk more about poland yeah yeah so near
poland and a lot of people are freaking
out it killed 35 people right it was
well it was just miles from the polish
border but i want to talk about
something that isn't necessarily
what everyone is discussing regarding
poland i don't think that russia wants
to go into poland but
let me let's play this clip first
breaking this morning at least 35 people
are dead 134 injured after a deadly
airstrike against a military base near
la vie in western ukraine the strike
hits an international peacekeeping and
security center just about 20 miles from
ukraine's border with poland this comes
a day after russian tanks rolled through
the streets of mary opal ukrainian
soldiers took cover inside buildings as
people ducked behind whatever they could
find to protect themselves the city has
been left for days without power and
water now just to be clear of course
you'd be a heartless prick to not have
any feelings of empathy watching that i
want to be clear with right just so not
a mouthpiece for putin right here that's
not what we're saying
that's awful to see of course now that
being said the concern here right is you
were saying yeah a lot of people think
that the very next step for russia is to
go into a place like poland and not stop
with ukraine and i don't know that that
is 100
what they're thinking or even 100 what
the people on maybe my side of the line
would say that's actually going to
happen but it's a real possibility and
threat in the back of our minds going
okay he's crazy enough to go into
ukraine right i don't view poland as
much more of an obstacle than maybe
ukraine i know they are better prepared
you're absolutely incorrect right well i
know that you this is you are absolutely
incorrect poland would put up a much
more significant fight than ukraine for
a couple of reasons first off poland is
like that poland is is like that kid
they were forced to eat a lot of crap
you look at world war ii they sort of
became a mock all the world war they
said yeah
come on don't rub it in listen sorry
they've had it tough enough then the
pollock jokes uh we're sorry poland
hamtramck you guys had your own spot
there in michigan now you hear the call
to prayer sorry we don't know where you
guys have to go
but poland uh it's like that kid in the
teddy atlas cutout you used to get in
the in comic books where you know the
bully kicks sand in his face and steals
his girlfriend and then he comes back
after doing his teddy sorry teddy atlas
not teddy atlas what was it uh charles
charles atlas is the trainer teddy mike
i'm older than dirk yeah charles atlas
and the kid comes back after doing the
charles atlas isometrics he's like
unhand my girlfriend bully and because
she can't make her own decisions and
then he takes the girl back
which slaps the bully yeah but that's
that's poland poland has been through so
much crap and they did they made the
conscious decision they said never again
and they've done that with a lot of sort
of international governing bodies too
where they've said no we're not gonna
we're not going to play your game with
rules your your game's out there we are
not going to let this happen again i
guarantee you also with poland unlike
ukraine a lot of people think that
ukraine they think that everybody there
is happy to fight for that government
that's not true that's not true they're
a lot of they're divided in ukraine
there are a lot of people who understand
the corruption of their government the
people in poland know what they're
fighting for as well not only are they
better trained not only are they
extremely capable sort of like taiwan
when you look at the numbers taiwan and
china you think they have no chance
actually the more you look into it sure
the united states will need to help them
but they have been setting a strategy up
for years because it's something that
they've been inspecting so has poland
and i guarantee you in poland they
wouldn't have to create a law that bars
milit that bars military-aged men from
leaving because they will sit there dig
their heels into polish soil and fight
and i think that cannot be
underestimated if you think that ukraine
was an embarrassment for russia and they
try to do some [ __ ] with poland it's
going to be a problem they've been
watching this they're stretching out
they're getting ready uh
yeah it wouldn't be easy well although
and they have marios putinowski yes they
do have marioski yeah who was that
he was one of the world's strongest men
while is he polish get a picture up what
is he going to do are you sure he's
polish no he's going to be that i
challenge you to fight yes oh he's he's
their champion he would be better than
elon musk yeah he would be better than
elon musk yeah well no look i know that
they're prepared and i know that they've
seen this coming for a long time but so
did the french prior to world war ii
right they said never again we're never
gonna let world war one happen again so
they obviously just listen if they tell
you to build a wall on the border don't
yeah but they're the french as you know
line part two doesn't work i get it but
what i'm saying is look even if poland
is prepared
how prepared can they possibly be
against
a completely unleashed russian military
right now i think russia might be
pulling some of their punches i think
they are very inept i think i think
we've seen that obviously the supply
chain issues that they've had getting
fuel you know to tanks to be able to
move in a convoy kind of an important
detail to make some drunken russian
pouring vegetable oil into the house
morale
no i agree it doesn't sit well when
you're when you're camped out in the
freeway with no gas uh drinking mother's
day from chernobyl well now here's the
problem you're sitting out in a freeway
in a war zone and you don't get picked
off right what the hell
it's just like sitting ducks it's like
hey we're going to hang out for a week
and yeah i mean you can target us if you
want yeah we can't surprise what
happened what is this what's
what's that sound i think it's a
ricochet what is this you weren't
trained at all were you i was drinking
heavily
we packed vodka yes
and he is polish he is polish oh yeah
he'll be able to fight three guys he'll
be waiting at the border yeah by the way
he's as natural as the rock
so here's something else i also again my
question has been where are all the
anti-war activists people now are saying
oh
poland poland what's going to happen to
paul we need to go in and defend poland
this is something that you may not know
about um people only do this when it's
politically expedient because the eu you
look at the un how they've been
constantly trying to shame poland in the
world stage places like poland places
like hungary why for being nationalists
for being and i don't mean white
nationalist ethno-nationalist i mean
believing in borders i mean saying
poland saying we're not going to take
mass numbers of migrants here saying no
we're not going to be sub subjugated
here to your lgbtq international agenda
so now these same people are saying oh
we're all poland we're all ukraine but
hold on a second just recently you tried
to you basically tried to censor poland
on the on the national stage let me read
this to you a lot of you may not know
this all references available at
lightweight.com this is according to the
eu
poland and hungary are not respecting
common eu laws and are accused of
curbing the freedom of courts media and
academics in addition they are accused
of depriving lgbtq
plus people and migrants of their rights
so how did hungary deprive lgbtq people
of the rights because keep in mind the
eu right this is a pretty powerful
entity yeah pretty powerful coalition is
saying you're denying these people of
rights you're you're violating human
rights well really it turns out that
hungary passed a law banning uh the
teaching of lgbtq aaip information to
minors in poland there have been a
hundred regions that declare that
they've declared themselves lgbtq
ideology free zones i'm liking poland
more and more
i had no idea and they also but i think
hungary believes in borders maybe a
little bit more than most yeah and
that's why they're a little bit and so
keep in mind too this is important at a
time when the two countries they've
taken in nearly two million combined
refugees from ukraine
the eu voted to block funding
wow so hey who's going to help ukraine
refugees poland hungary yeah yeah yeah
but they're not teaching uh they're not
teaching drag queen story hour to
four-year-olds so we've got to we've got
to punish them economically and then
when there's an invasion poland you'll
see all of these people talking about
how they're we are poland we are the
world well you tried to screw them
just because they're not you
i wonder what was different about the
refugees i know everybody's going to
point to it and be like oh are there
white people and they're europeans no i
think it's people aren't going to come
in and try to destroy their country yeah
i think it's mainly the rape
they didn't want that migrant rape
tends to tends to happen nothing
crawdaddy all right no no
they don't call him the best color man
in the business
i'm just listening to your your
brilliance no it's absolutely true i
mean they didn't fawn over them they
didn't deny right they just didn't fawn
over their silliness yeah i mean come on
yeah that's exactly it's like you denied
their rights wait do you mean hold on
look at this map really quickly pull it
up on cnn yeah belarus look at belarus
it's how many refugees have gone there
126. can you imagine being one of the
126 people and going to belarus and
being like ah this is just like russia
that's where russian troops are staged
what are you doing
you ran to the wrong country
it's out of the fire and into the bay
area ah quick oh we're running away and
they're like look good for us more
ukrainian yeah it's like oh jeez give
them uniforms send them to gulag that's
like slaves who thought they were
escaping to canada yeah well hey free
free labor more slaves eh
this is also something really funny i
was just watching this movie this uh
last week not a bad film four feathers
with heath ledger yeah and uh it was
1844 i believe is when it was set and uh
they're out there in the sudan fighting
and they have slaves and i'm sitting
there going yeah people always act as
though they ended slavery
in britain before the united states they
were using them everywhere that they
still had that well they didn't have an
empire in the uk they didn't have them
on the island
where they got all their resources from
stephen they i mean come on they had to
i just look i think what's really when
you're discussing war when you're
discussing something as severe as war
this is where consistency comes into
play and it needs to be more important
than ever because the severity the
consequences
are unbelievably dire you're talking
about people dying and you're talking
about throwing the world into chaos you
need to be consistent if you were just
punishing poland and hungry last week
you don't get to say that it's super
important that we go to war if anything
happens with them in russia you were
just screwing them last week if you last
year or two years ago three years ago
when donald trump was president you
weren't paying anywhere near your two
percent of spending in nato you don't
get to come out and say well nato's more
important than ever and this is why we
created this alliance and and donald
trump weakened and they don't know he
just wanted you to pay your fair share
you've just got to be consistent and i
just am not seeing any consistency
honestly from the left and from a lot of
republicans as well it's very
disappointing yeah there's a lot of
republicans right now that i'm a little
pissed off at that are pushing for war
every single minute that they can
they're pushing for something that would
start a war at the very least sending
fighters through our base come on just
bring the pilots and let them fly the
plane that being said i think if they do
invade poland okay it's time for the
united states to make some decisions
that's where you either go all in or you
i wish we would have been all out so we
could have gone all in with poland so
there'd be a contrast right but instead
we've taken these half measures i think
the statement needs to be made with
poland if you're gonna make one but you
guys comment let me know what you think
if you disagree and uh you can also i
don't know if you know this you can
smash that like button if you're
watching on youtube
so this is something you'll love this uh
look at that
i might want to change that giant green
fist because i'm about to talk about
pete butt kick
oh my goodness
yeah i don't want look i don't want to
cause a bro it was a hulk reference okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or it was his
favorite
intimate shop
i think it'd be a different hulk it
still has pants on most of the time so
yeah exactly would be a different hulk
the only thing that would rip would be
it's like oh yes there's show me the oh
come on it's still got the pants oh the
hulk just only his pants rip off but he
still has his shark tooth necklace
oh smash pete ah oh no
oh how come your pants always become
chaps
[Laughter]
hulk falls from street smash
[Laughter]
every time he transitions his song is
just what is love maybe they don't hurt
me no i'm going to hurt you all right
so uh or it's a share song hulk has a
share wall
so pete buttgig's husband before we get
to sexy summer camps and this is a real
problem joe louis what the hell are you
doing why is he being so difficult today
well he doesn't like when he saw you
dancing kind of feminine
femininely all right the gerald here you
set the you set up this first clip since
crawdaddy just uh since uh joe lewis got
his time all right so uh you know the
thing that we told you uh was going to
happen and they told you would never
happen is happening right in front of
your eyes and this is just more evidence
of it
butt giggs husband led children in the
pledge of allegiance to the gay pride
flag the what
wow that's not all right
we missed the
[Applause]
with affirmation and equal rights for
all
by the way he says that when he's not
waving a flag
watcher watch your heads
do they get tense by the way he says did
he say atypical can i hear that again
the first part of he said what the not
so typical that's the typical not so
typical so what do you mean what is the
typical queer camp for kids i'm i'm
confused i don't know i mean it's less
than two percent of population earth i
would already think that's not so
typical
but why are you pledging allegiance do
you understand what the pledge of
allegiance is and what you just made it
yeah it means you like dicks but no no
that's not what it's about well then i
don't know up is down down is up it's
more than that you basically took what
was supposed to kind of reunite a
country right and say you're pledging
allegiance to an ideal of freedom and
democracy democratic republic not just
democracy and now you said
you're pledging allegiance to a sexual
thing well yeah but would a flag by any
other colors make him as horny
or children pledging allegiance to
though i'm not saying he's a pedophile
i'm just saying when you lead children
in that kind of pledge and you make it
about sexuality because there's nothing
well it isn't the name it's sexual
orientation that's the thing it's sexual
orientation they separated that from
gender you can't explain it with
without explaining what the sex and
sexual orientation is by the way they
also do that at camp orientation so pete
pete pete butt giggs husband um what is
sex
yeah that's exactly what the first
answer is
that you the head counselor grooming the
entire room yes yeah well sex is when a
man loves it i mean when a man loves a
in anything or anything and they could
be married or could be not or whatever
uh uh the man uh you know because
when it's for procreate well it's not
for procreation it doesn't have to have
purpose for procreation the penis goes
into you know uh what wherever you want
whatever you want to do uh pledge
allegiance to this flag and we have
sparkle cookies set up your tent and
have at it yes let me just show you
yeah
it's easier to demonstrate than it is
yeah the visual aids which brings us to
our next topic aids now this camp is
riddled with it
you're going to want to watch it riddled
your category
rhett goes up crying out loud the pledge
of allegiance is such a solemn beautiful
thing yeah and then to bastardize it
like this
especially when the slogan for that camp
is shh don't tell
yeah
what happens at camp stays hey what's
that uh what's that one this is my learn
how to keep a secret badge
how could they get the rainbow just
let's just let that happen what did we
lose just a vault sewn into his shoulder
all right
[Laughter]
if you don't see what's wrong with this
then there is no hope for you okay
i look i get it some kid would rather
play with barbies and play with g.i joes
fine don't send him to a camp with a man
who was breastfeeding an adoptive child
with the secretary of transportation
you're just asking for trouble
call me old-fashioned so these women in
kentucky now they're setting up this
isn't the only uh thing they're pledging
allegiance but this is the sexualization
of children we've talked about this
we've gotten on trouble on youtube for
talking about this because they say if
you question the sexualization of
children oh you're making fun of
someone's immutable characteristics this
has nothing to do with the children okay
it has to do with the predators and i
don't necessarily mean just sexual
predators i mean ideological predators
who are trying to get their claws into
your kids very young so this is sexy
summer camp in kentucky for kids the
lessons include things like sex
liberation
gender exploration
bdsm
being a sex worker self-managed
abortions what sex on licit and illicit
drugs now hold on a second look look
look
look
if you want to say first off if you
wanted to say this is an lgbt friendly
camp where we make sure that no one gets
bullied you know i don't know we teach
knitting classes whatever the hell it is
fine so in here if you just want let's
say it was just gender exploration i
disagree with it but you would say that
we are either straw manning or employing
an intellectual fallacy if we go on
that's a slippery slope to discuss
gender and sexual orientation with kids
because then then this devolves into a
hypersexual conversation no what do you
think we're all perverts but then when
they have the ability to they're
teaching bdsm being a sex worker why do
kids need to know that
and what do you do it
take your mom to work day
take your moms to work day
well are they both sex workers
self-managed abortions
i don't even i don't even do my own
taxes
i don't even know what that means
honestly specs on illicit and illicit
drugs illicit means illegal in this
context right so okay not only are you
teaching them how to be gross but how to
break the law
so you guys have heard of bill cosby
we're gonna do a class lesson everybody
drink up he got some things wrong but a
lot right
well the gay community should completely
renounce this thing yes of course
absolutely these guys don't get to run
on the track that they've built over
decades right and that's what's happened
the whole acronym wants to run on their
track yeah what happened to free to love
who you want became this
i think we should have straight camps
it should be debauchery camp yeah yeah
well
it is a degenerate camp i listen i
thought that when we were talking about
young girls that we were talking about
the hypersexualization of young girls
and how that was damaging women 15 20
years ago this was everything that you
heard about what was going on with women
because of posters and unrealistic
expectations and sexualizing at an early
age and now you're wanting
four-year-olds to have these
conversations where what happened
you stopped caring about women you
started caring about well also you don't
understand that uh the stereotypes of
beautiful women you know looking for
example like a barbie doll or i don't
know you could take marilyn monroe
audrey hepburn these awful horrible
stereotypes are completely unacceptable
except for when a man decides that he's
a woman then that's how they all look
well they all are like i'm a woman where
women go i'm more you know that's not
what determines our experience as not
just our body parts right well how is
that a trans man a woman well he
switched some body parts
what is it so what defines womanhood is
makeup what defines womanhood is putting
on a dress and a wig and
don't forget the wig yeah don't forget
that it makes it harder if you're going
to be getting a wig so
this is this is yes it's that's just
where we are it's the stereotype is fine
as long as it's trans and it's all right
well then it's brave and beautiful i
mean think of caitlyn jenner
think of caitlyn jenner was wearing a
corset in that dress you would have
bitched about that that magazine cover
yeah
to kingdom come if it was just some
random oh look it's airbrushed oh look
at this dress this is unrealistic look
at these dimensions oh it's a man saying
he's little oh how wonderful and
beautiful i'm right woman of the year
yeah woman of the year
they do complain about that i'm trying
to think jennifer lawrence in that one
where she's the russian the sparrow
thing like the spy it's not not a great
movie but they were like how dare you
have to wear this dress in the photo
shoot with all your other actor friends
yeah i'm like oh yeah because that's the
biggest problem we've got because
society the reason that women like
dressing up is society
so the camp's founder of sexy i want to
make sure i get this name right sexy
summer camp i keep saying sexy day camp
but at summer camp it's more than a day
more than a day good it's a sleepover
camp which makes me feel far more at
ease with the general concept so the
camp's founder tanya turner all
references available at
lighthousecutter.com even talked about
how important
masturbating is for children get down
with yourself explore your own body
masturbation is really healthy and i
recommend it to people of all ages wrong
all ages as soon as my name is talk they
were doing that that's what they were
doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt t you can touch your nose but my
scissors not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right but
it feels good right we have to learn
ways to talk to young people about this
so that they know how to explore their
body consensually so that it's not in
public right well if you were to explore
your body you'd need globes and maps
well what's wrong with it
why can't it be in public then if your
nose is in public right yeah just tug
away yeah
cuban was right all this time explore
your body consensually you ask yourself
permission to touch yourself i once told
stephen to stop or he'd go blind
he said dad screw him over here
how many fingers am i holding up
i needed glasses but the joke's on you i
got this lasik please
i'll always get lasik dad i still have
stretch marks so they'll invent lasik
when i get older
it's uh
this of all ages now i get it boys touch
themselves shirt but that's not
masturbating that's not the same thing
as a boy touching himself or you know
guys often when they're sitting watching
television right you just put your hand
on your pants for some reason i don't
know why and i feel like i'm like i
don't even realize i was doing that
never did it's warm yeah
exactly i mean it's a temperate climate
that's what it is but teaching it's bald
me
teaching
kids of all ages to masturbate in other
words you know what's going to be going
on at the camp
it's like
why do you why do you imply that there's
anything inappropriate because she's
going to teach five-year-olds to
masturbate even before that i have a son
right now who's starting to talk and
she's saying my son should be schooled
in the arts of
self-pleasure and went just to make sure
that we understood her correctly she
said all ages
all ages and had it in bold on the
screen there
i i if i say words right now can we back
you back kind of like you know
earmarking a bill can we back door
legislation in and just put a weight
limit
i think so like yes unless you meet the
super heavyweight category in which case
um well we'll cut off both hands so that
you can't oh my gosh spoil it for the
rest of us i'm sorry these people are
gone i'm sorry this is done yeah it's
time these people do not belong in the
village you are not that's enough
it's enough we don't need to wait until
a child is sexually accosted to say you
know what we're not comfortable with you
uh targeting our children no this is
enough it doesn't need to be child rape
and you guys can let me know if you
think that i'm being too extreme here
this should be shut down i'm period
relatively libertarian relatively you
know uh
i mean i was a libertarian until i kind
of grew up like there is a fundamental
role of government however public safety
definitely falls under the rule of
government not what you put in your own
body if you're not harming anybody else
not what you choose to do on your own
property if you're not harming anybody
else but this is definitely a violation
of public safety when you are going
after children and teaching them at a
summer camp to masturbate and about bdsm
for crying out loud when do we say that
you know what a society with some
semblance of decency would be nice
libertarians can you can you agree on
that it's like oh if they want to do it
that's fine well first off right now
this is just a camp okay we understand
that this lady is putting it on because
you know she probably needs some
reason to roll out of bed in the morning
and so this was her reason at that point
but you you don't think that this is
going to go down the road of eventually
getting a government grant
government funding of course then it
becomes taxpayer-funded teaching
children to masturbate that's why they
had that bill in florida and people said
oh it's a don't say gay bill no it was
you can't teach kids
what will eventually include as you're
seeing in this camp
masturbating
that's enough we need a society where we
say okay you know what this is we used
to say sex sex ed was a debate yeah
where some people were saying you know
what i think that i should be able to
teach my uh children and some parents
dropped the ball and didn't teach their
kids and they got old you had like a
loretta lynn situation where she had
babies she didn't even know where they
came from i just thought that was
something you did for fun that's a
problem
we all agree that one's on the lens
talking about the coal miner's daughter
yeah oh okay
when i was a euphemism
that's how she thought the engagement
ring is just i must have gotten from the
mine on pressure
so a screw-up got it but the
conversation used to be about where is
there this level of propriety for a
parent
what rights do a parent do parents
maintain yeah in teaching these things
to their children they would say well
you just want to teach abstinence only
education and it doesn't work by the way
abstinence only education means that
abstinence is the only thing that
actually works 100 of the time that's a
scientific fact doesn't mean that you
teach us the only way to mitigate
pregnancy that it's the only way to
mitigate stds but it is the only way
that is foolproof period there can be no
debate about that scientifically that
being said the people who thought that
it was their job to teach sex education
to kids were excoriated they were all
made to look like carrie's mom with the
kitchen silverware in her torso in that
final scene and the fact is those same
parents are saying well where does it
end
where does it end what rights do we give
up and teach well now they believe that
they should have the right to teach your
kids about bdsm and masturbating all
ages and they reiterate all ages and
being a sex worker don't forget we gotta
bring this economy
yeah because we don't want to objectify
women hey just so you know
i i don't know if you're aware of this
because this is something i've never
really understood when the left says uh
you know you shouldn't objectify women
and by that they mean objectify women by
actually acknowledging and appreciating
the beauty of women i don't know if you
know this but i've been known to do that
right
to appreciate that women can be
beautiful i know
i know
shame you can you can shame me you can
admonish me but
uh they think that that is wrong okay
and by the way i mean the left i mean
the people at these camps i mean the
people who uh run the media and run all
of all of hollywood they right now in
these magazines they say it's fat pride
it's it's wrong to objectify it's wrong
to appreciate the beauty of this woman
but they support sex work and sex work
is real work hey let me ask you this
when a guy pulls up to a sex worker
what do you think he's doing
that woman only makes money
if she's objectified
don't objectify women
by the way sex work is real work what do
you teach them you're teaching them
about a 401k or you teach them how to be
more effective sex worker hey i'll give
you a hint to be the most effective sex
worker you want to be be the most
attractive you can be to members of the
opposite sex it's almost like that's the
only thing they care about don't
objectify women sex work is real work oh
all right okay got it you have no
problem when it's just some guy in the
back of a metro geo just as long as
they're not modeling for a magazine
understood now um and the don't say gay
crowd completely misses it again they've
got to detach from this this is a bridge
too far for them yeah if they're legit
they've got to disconnect completely
this is
yeah
i think absolutely and
any bridge is a bridge too far for that
lady
even on an electric bicycle
the only action she's getting is
self-love well i don't know that
she would turn herself down every time i
don't know if she can reach she gives
herself the date rape if she was going
the way the crow flies if straight but
not if you have to you know
[Laughter]
it's like you know you're not going like
it's like going to new york from l.a but
you have to go you have to stop in
chicago i fly direct now
[Music]
there was also supposed to be a sexy
summer camp in texas uh but it was
postponed teens there were going to be
paid a hundred dollars to go learn quote
an evidence-based
and lgbtq
there it is i a
plus friendly curriculum well which is
it
which one is it is it evidence-based or
is it
lgbtqia plus friendly those can't be in
the same sentence which one is it let's
just go through that really quickly let
me read this okay so that you guys can
actually see how absurd this is and
these are the people who say trust the
science yeah trust the science
okay an evidence-based and instead of
the acronym i'll read this an
evidence-based and
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
intersex
and it's a allies
plus sexual maybe i don't know asexual
plus
evidence based and then just an
insertion of a bunch of made-up [ __ ]
and the plus is like if we forgot to
make anything else anything else we want
to feel free
i don't know hey and then someone goes
like hey i don't know i'm at this camp
and since you guys seem to be so uh very
uh meticulous about being evidence-based
can i be too spirited oh yeah you could
be two spirit we'll just add that to the
list what does that mean i don't know i
don't know edit hey can i be pansexual
yeah i thought i just want to make sure
with your whole evidence-based uh
curriculum
i like all the tents in the camp yeah
excuse me was a little bear what was it
with dustin hoffman what was that movie
oh uh something bear little big man
little big man little big man they're
gonna little big man every single tent
oh jeez good reference it's a solid one
you have to check that and they're
evidence-based way back cbtqia
plus this is what they do right this is
how they justify it with your children
this is how they justify all of it this
is why science science the scientific
process is a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing because it
involves testing something you have a
hypothesis you test it and it's not
based on consensus science it's not
determined by consensus i should say
it's determined by truth it doesn't
matter what the consensus is if the
truth is revealed and it happens to go
against the consensus so what they try
and do is bastardize that and say
actually 97 of scientists agree on the
climate change well actually look uh
most of these doctors now are willing to
perform uh sex uh reassignment surgery
well actually if you look at the dsm-5
they change gender dysphoria so they
change it so it's no longer an actual uh
disorder it's the symptoms are in fact
uh these are
i don't know if you know this you know
what the dsm-5 changed dsm-4 dsm-5 used
to be gender dysphoria was a disorder
just like body dysmorphia okay just like
anorexia just like bodybuilders gender
dysphoria was seen as a disorder as a
way because of political pressure as a
way to counter to them they changed it
where gender dysphoria is a means to
describe the symptoms
of uh the discomfort from being born
with the wrong gender identity
so it's the same symptoms of the
disorder but the fix is not what used to
be is youth these are people who have a
disorder where they believe that they're
a boy when they're a girl so it operated
from they believe that they are
something that they are biologically not
and they changed it to say well actually
the disorder now
these are the symptoms that they feel
because they were born in the wrong body
and it's still called gender dysphoria
how's that scientifically based and when
did that happen when did that happen do
you have the studies this is one thing i
got into arguments with people on this
show um
actually uh one of them and who ended up
becoming a friend blaire white who was
on the show and then another person who
we knew who um uh actually went to texas
to get uh
i won't name them but a gender
reassignment surgery they went to a
doctor um dr sergey kotchikakov
well-known
well-known
highly esteemed very in his field
scalpel to me but
i don't know what was i saying about
what they said before
you just wanted to get to that name
i don't know
oh you know what yeah we're the studies
so you want to say okay we change this
to dsm-5 because that assumes that
someone can be born in the wrong body
okay again let's do this let's do let's
just go through the scientific process
and let's sort of combine it a little
bit with socratic method oh so someone
believes they're born in the wrong body
why
right there it's either they were born
in the wrong body you have to answer or
well they have a disorder that tells
them that they were born in the wrong
body okay so let's say you go with that
door number one they were born in the
wrong body how do you know that
you don't get much further than that now
some people might say well it's because
their brain is in the wrong body oh so
what you mean to say is there's a male
brain and a female brain which would
again bring us back to this oppressive
idea of a binary how can you have a male
brain in a female brain if you don't
have biological sex but even then
are there studies that show the brain of
trans people are different before
cross-sex hormone replacement therapy
doesn't exist
it's not a thing
but we change the disorder
to mean the symptoms of a disorder
without actually identifying how
somebody can be born into the wrong body
they can't answer the simple follow-up
question of what do you mean someone's
born in the wrong body
well it's because they're
born into the brain is born in the wrong
body how do you know that
there isn't an answer for any of that
yeah but they want to teach your
children
an evidence-based curriculum just don't
don't be led by the nose okay don't be
led by the nose on this because you need
to understand the severity of
this is this is not one of those things
where people say okay you have an
opinion and we haven't
this is uncharted territory
this is a massive social experiment and
the subjects are now your children
this has never happened
in the modern in the history of the
modern world it's never happened you
don't know how this ends we do know that
there's a 42 41 to 42 attempted suicide
rate for transgender youth and we do
know that after surgery it doesn't get
any better after sex hormone replacement
surgery or after gender reassignment
surgery it's still about 41 42
so it's not scientifically viable to say
that these people
find themselves in an unnaturally high
suicide rate higher than american slaves
because they can't take a dump at a
target or camp crystal lake
maybe there's something else going on
and maybe if we want to help our
children first off we shouldn't be
hypersexualizing them but maybe we
should actually
be seeing if there's a root cause
of the problem
that isn't just tossed under the lgbtqia
unironically you can go to the reference
plus
moniker because that doesn't help
anybody speaking of which we're going to
play what the flag here on mug club
which we no way in no way could play on
youtube so youtube you can uh you can
well you can urinate off
do